[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
a judge allows a lawsuit between the
potatoes and brian laundry's family to
move forward plus a murder conviction
overturned will tex macgyver get a new
trial for the death of his wife and
after 43 days on the run a suspected
killer is found and caught by u.s
marshals in a different country but
first she points her fingers at everyone
she can possibly name including people
that are thousands of miles away in
minnesota
and i would posit the question why why
would she murder savannah closing
arguments are presented in the missouri
case against rebecca rood a mother
charged with killing and burning the
body of her 16-year-old daughter long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmart closing
arguments are presented in missouri
versus rebecca rude as she faces
first-degree murder for the death of her
16-year-old daughter savannah leckie
rude is accused of killing and burning
the body of her daughter in ozark county
in 2017. savannah was adopted at birth
by tamil leki montague and david leckie
a couple who divorced shortly before
savannah's death savannah who had
special needs began struggling with
behavioral problems as a teen while
still with her adopted mother lucky
montague and brood agreed to have
savannah move back in with her
biological mother and her boyfriend
robert p
eleven months later rood reported her
daughter missing prosecutors say rude
abused savannah and that she and pete
eventually killed her and burned her
body investigators searched at ozark
county farm and found bone fragments and
teeth in a burn pile pete who is also
charged in savannah's murder testified
against ruud prosecutors presented
several witnesses including local law
enforcement volunteer firefighters
neighbors and friends of rudes and
former inmates who she allegedly
confessed to crimes
after three days of testimony being
presented solely before a judge
attorneys presented their closing
arguments thursday prosecutors posed the
question if the defendant's story is
true why did she lead people to believe
savannah was still alive despite
admitting to burning her body
how do we know savannah how do we know
the defendant killed savannah defendant
destroyed the body
you know this from saints exhibit number
17.
that was the teeth and the jawbone
recovered from the burn pile
there was barely anything left of
savanni lucky
enough to fit into a bag
that's how
terrible the defendant's treatment of
savannah lucky was law enforcement
officers from several agencies ozark
county sheriff's office baxter county
arkansas sheriff's office
highway patrol civilians firefighters
perhaps 100 people
are out there on this 81 acre farm
scouring it looking for savannah
believing that savannah had run away she
points her fingers at everyone she can
possibly name including people that are
thousands of miles away in minnesota
as being involved in savannah's
disappearance despite knowing where
savannah was in the barn pile because
she placed her there she killed her and
placed her there
while the case rood's attorneys argued
she didn't kill her daughter but admits
to burning her body only after savannah
kills herself in their closing argument
they argue the state didn't prove a
murder took place at all
the state
kind of posits the question of of why
why would reba why would rita destroy
savannah's body if nothing sinister or
nothing bad happened there
and i would posit the question why why
would she murder savannah
what was what was going so wrong there
that
that she would have that she would have
progressed suddenly to murder
the evidence of murder that the state
wants to present is that the destruction
of the body must mean murder there's a
whole lot of other reasons
as to why
why savannah ended up dying
and
unlike the state ours is supported by
medical evidence it's a stretch
and it certainly goes against everything
that we as lawyers learn in law school
we learn that we believe foundations
that we can't just jump to certain
things that simply because
something because someone says well
that's this must have been a murder
there has to be more there has to be
more evidence to support the actual
murder what the state does have the
state has evidence to show
that that there are abandonment other
courts the state can absolutely prove
that reba burns savannah's body
but that's all they can prove
the judge is expected to announce his
verdict by july 15th joining us today is
legal analyst matt mangino and co-host
terry austin matt is the defense right
did the prosecution not prove their case
to you are there any issues that you
think the judge will have in deciding
this case
well you know i think that they drove
home the point that the prosecution has
the responsibility to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that there's been a
murder um you know we we know and they
candidly admit that she's responsible
for destroying uh savannah's body uh you
know after her death but you know has
the prosecution met their burden of
proof with regard to proving that there
was a murder um you know all that they
have are
jail house informants and those are not
the most reliable witnesses uh when it
comes to trying to prove your case in
this instance to a judge not even a jury
just a judge so so i i think um they put
a plausible defense forward all right
terry let's ask on the other side of
this coin why do you think the
prosecution proved their case and the
defense didn't poke holes in it
well i have to say if this had been
before a jury i think the prosecution
might have a good chance of winning for
the reasons that matt just stated but
this is before the judge and a judge is
going to listen to all of this evidence
and determine whether or not the
prosecution actually met its burden i
think what the prosecution did well is
to demonstrate that there's no question
the body was burned and she tried to
hide that she said that she was missing
she basically tampered with the evidence
by burning the body that's consciousness
of guilt and so the judge can consider
all of that but he may very well ha you
know hold the prosecution to that very
high standard of beyond a reasonable
doubt and that's why it was a great idea
to have this before a judge absolutely
well we'll see how this plays out what
is it july 15th we'll get a verdict and
and we'll not going to be like a jury
trial verdict but we'll make sure we'll
get it to hear the law on crime daily
still ahead on law and crime daily a
former prominent atlanta attorney's
murder conviction is overturned what
that means protects macgyver's case in
the 2016 shooting death of his wife but
first following weeks on the run a
suspected killer is captured now caitlyn
armstrong faces deportation back to the
u.s after being caught in costa rica
[Music]
welcome back after weeks on the run a
texas woman accused of fatally shooting
an elite cyclist has been captured in
costa rica according to u.s marshals 34
year old caitlin marie armstrong is
accused of killing anna wilson in texas
may 11th armstrong was in a relationship
with and living with her boyfriend colin
strickland at the time strickland said
he had dated wilson last year while he
and armstrong were separated
investigators believe the shooting may
have been a violent act of romantic
jealousy police issued a warrant for
armstrong days after the shooting but
she wasn't found until this past
wednesday after 43 days u.s marshals
arrested her at a hotel in costa rica
investigators previously said armstrong
used a fake passport to fly from newark
to san jose on may 18th but costa rican
officials say her passport was real it
just didn't match her identity armstrong
will be deported back to the u.s to face
charges but there is no specific date
when she will return
terry the first question a judge will
have to determine when armstrong is in
court is bail do you think she will get
any or be held until trial
i think she's going to be held for trial
because i would not if i were the judge
grant bail under these circumstances one
of the main considerations for bail is
whether or not it's a flight risk here
we already know that she went after this
individual to costa rica she flew from
newark and you know she had a warrant
for her arrest and she wasn't found
until six weeks later so i think that
you know she was using someone else's
passport and the fact is with that type
of situation the judge is probably going
to deny bail
whether she's a danger to others it
remains to be seen but why take any
chances that she'll you know risk flight
again and i think the judge is going to
keep her in jail
all right matt
i'm going to be a public defender and
lay on the side i'm gonna let you make
the bail arguments i'm gonna take a
break for it so what are the defense's
arguments for why bail should not be set
in a case like this where as terry said
there's so many strong arguments
well the first thing that i would argue
is and i'm not exactly sure but you know
if she has no uh criminal history you
you want to make that clear to the to
the court does she have ties to the
community where she's going to live um
you know has she um you know had any any
problems in the past uh with regard to
to
being uh evasive or leaving town uh
unexpectedly i mean
you know quite frankly uh i want wanna
zealously represent my clients in every
case but this is gonna be a tough sell
uh as terry said i mean she left the
country uh with this homicide charge
over her head um and and and she did it
in in a way in which she used a passport
that didn't belong to her
i mean
even ashley bailey would have a tough
time with this argument for val you know
we'll see what happens though when that
eventually does come because there's
going to be a bail argument made in this
case well thank you both for your inputs
coming up on law on crime daily a murder
conviction overturned we're looking at
the case of tex mcgiver who was charged
and convicted for the death of his wife
plus a lawsuit between the petito family
and the laundry family is moving forward
details on the denial of a motion to
dismiss
[Music]
welcome back in georgia a former atlanta
lawyer is granted a new trial as claude
tex macgyver's murder conviction is
overturned macgyver was convicted in the
shooting death of his wife diane
mccouple was driving home from a party
with a friend when macgyver allegedly
shot his wife through the front seat as
he sat in the back seat of their suv
during the trial there was testimony
that macgyver shot the gun as a result
of being startled awake and that he
suffered from a sleep disorder which
could cause involuntary movements he was
convicted of murder and sentenced to
life in prison the state supreme court
this week ruled jurors should have been
allowed to consider a misdemeanor
involuntary manslaughter charge not only
murder the judge said the reason they
should have had that option was because
the evidence of macgyver's guilt was not
strong enough he argues from evidence
during the trial the jury could have
concluded he didn't intentionally shoot
his wife but that it was an accident
terry with charges dismissed from the
trial court and now charges overturned
from the supreme court if there's a
retrial what would the charges be
you know the prosecution is thinking
about that as we speak and what she's
trying to consider is what will the
evidence show she could still
charge with a murder charge not the
malice murder but the felony murder but
she has been instructed by the court
that she should have put in and included
a lesser charge so we'll see if she
decides to go for the you know home run
here or if she just puts in the lesser
charge and there's another option brian
she could just not bring any charges at
all whatsoever one of the things that
the supreme court said was look there
wasn't a lot of evidence here that this
was murder and so we might even see that
they just decide to pass all together
and he's already served over four years
and if in fact he were convicted of
anything else he's probably served most
of his time so she may just pass yeah
matt
from what the judge is saying it are
they saying that macgyver should not
have been found guilty of the murder
charges he was convicted of based on the
reasoning and how does that affect
whether or not we have a retrial
well i think as i understand um the
court's uh decision
what they alluded to was that the malice
murder charge he was acquitted of so
there wasn't sufficient evidence to
prove uh malice murder he was convicted
of felony murder but they're saying that
because of of the jury's
decision in this case they should have
had the option to review the involuntary
manslaughter charge as well and that not
instructing the jury uh on that
lesser included offense
uh that they didn't have an opportunity
to consider it and uh that was
prejudicial to the defendant in this
case and he's entitled to a new trial
all right we'll keep ozone in this case
because whether it's a new trial or no
trial at all that would be a massive
breaking news considering how this case
went down when we first followed it
well in california prosecutors claim the
alleged killer of rapper nipsey hussell
came strapped and loaded with two guns
and a plan to shoot him dead as closing
arguments were presented in the trial of
eric holder jr thursday after three
years of delays defendant eric holder jr
faced his jury trial
over the last two weeks on charges of
first-degree murder attempted murder and
assault with a deadly weapon holder was
arrested in april of 2019 less than a
week after he allegedly shot nipsy
hustle in front of the rapper's marathon
clothing store police say a dispute
broke out between the two men after
hustle accused holder of being a snitch
investigators say a holder left the
store then returned with two weapons and
shot nipsy hustle a medical examiner
found the rapper was shot at least 10
times with the bullets piercing his
lungs and severing his spinal cord a
witness alleges holder told nipsey
hustle after the shots were fired quote
you're through
the judge previously ruled there would
be limited media coverage allowed on the
trial only allowing cameras for the
opening statements and closing arguments
prosecutors presented their closing
arguments thursday telling the jury the
killing was planned
but as she turned that block back on the
slots and she saw him manipulating
what she saw for the first time that day
the black semi-automatic handgun looked
like he was putting bullets in
the magazine
and she
alarmed that he was going to shoot
either her or out the car she said
you're not about to shoot for my car
and he just kind of shrugs it off and
puts the gun away he was he was already
planning to kill nixie hustle
that's planning
that's premeditation and deliberation
that's thinking about it before you do
it he puts on his shirt for the first
time that day
why
because he knows
he's going back
he's already planning that
there's no reason for him to walk around
all day with no shirt on get in the car
and then all of a sudden put the shirt
on in the car
he's putting that shirt on
he gave him
whatever element of surprise he can get
holder's attorneys say he admits to
shooting nipsy hustle but that he denies
it was premeditated on the next episode
of law and crime daily hear from
holder's defense attorney as he presents
his closing argument
when we come back a judge rules on a
motion to dismiss as a civil lawsuit
stemming from the death of gabby petito
at the hands of brian laundry can move
forward
welcome back to law and crime daily
heading now to south carolina where
tiger king's star doc antle has been
indicted on 10 new charges just days
after being released from jail the owner
of myrtle beach safari is back in the
attention of federal law enforcement the
netflix star and three of his employees
now face wildlife trafficking and money
laundering charges before allegedly
violated two federal wildlife statutes
the lacey act and endangered species act
by creating fake records involving the
movement of endangered animals if
convicted they will be forced to forfeit
all illegally acquired animals and any
vehicles used while moving them anto was
just granted 250 dollar bond and
released tuesday after spending three
weeks in jail for federal money
laundering charges anto faces a possible
25-year prison sentence and faces
separate animal trafficking charges in
virginia
and in florida a judge has ruled a
lawsuit brought about by gabby potito's
parents against brian laundry's parents
will move forward gabby's disappearance
last summer gripped the nation after she
and her boyfriend brian ventured out on
a cross-country wide trip
in their converted van
gabby was found dead in wyoming killed
by strangulation according to
investigators after returning home alone
brian went missing his body was found
weeks later dead by suicide in march the
potatoes filed a lawsuit against the
laundries arguing they knew brian had
killed gabby and then a month later
added to their complaint alleging
intentional infliction of emotional
distress the laundry's moved to dismiss
on thursday a judge announced he will
allow the lawsuit to proceed the
laundry's lawyer argued his clients were
acting within their constitutional
rights to remain silent throughout the
investigation a jury trial for the
lawsuit is scheduled for august of next
year
so
matt
how can the potato family prove what the
laundries may have known from a private
conversation about gabby's death isn't
that going to make this case an uphill
battle for them
well they allege
that uh the laundries knew about gabby's
death as as early as august 28 before
brian laundry even
came back down but that's only an
allegation and and i'm sure the potatoes
are going to deny that allegation but
what it does is it opens the door to
depose the dipita uh the potatoes and to
other people and to ask them questions
under oath about what they knew when
they knew it and about their lawyer
statement
that that they were hoping for the um
return
of gabby uh
you know all which leads to this issue
of emotional distress and that's the
that's what they're alleging in their
complaint now terry you previously
thought the judge would deny the motion
dismiss why do you think the judge
allowed the case to proceed to trial
you know it's very difficult to win a
motion to dismiss and you can make this
type of motion for a bunch of reasons
statute of limitations you can say the
court doesn't have jurisdiction you can
say the plaintiff doesn't have standing
but here what the motion was was
basically saying look there's not a
cause of action here even with the facts
it doesn't support this cause of action
intentional infliction of emotional
distress and so the attempt was to get
that case dismissed i think the judge
prefers to let it go to a jury and in
order to prove it obviously you have to
have an intentional or reckless act you
have to have outrageous conduct that
causes this severe emotional harm the
judge prefers to let a jury decide those
issues and decided to let the case go
forward well we will obviously be
following that case as it does matt
terry thank you and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you